important
thank you John well good evening and
welcome to members officers of the
public here at the meeting and those
that are joining us
lecture
um just before the meeting kicks off can
I just introduce Gordon Bryant on the
back of the good stand up Gordon
Gordon is replacing David Hayes our
finance manager on Section 151 officer
children welcome I hope you enjoy your
time
students
[Music]
okay 101 apologies
thank you chair thank you answer four
pencil adult counselor Whittaker pencil
Wheatley councilor Pennington said he
may be late and Stacey Glory head of
legal thank you
the item two is to confirm the minutes
of the last meeting of Paul Council on
the 19th of June
Pages 5 to 17 just run through the pages
on the first one page five
six
seven
[Music]
eight
nine
and
eleven
twelve
what that's great
sorry coming out with minutes well it's
just for accuracy at the moment
um you know possibility then okay
so on page 13
page 14.
15.
16 and 17.
so what I'm looking for is a proposal
that learn treatment because there's a
lot of people talking about correctly
yeah
[Music]
yes
and your sanctions
in 27.2 again
moving on item three public
contributions
[Music]
of the energy
uh report from the finance officer and
there are some
questions raised about either knew of
whatever the energy elements energy
Supply
we were quite rushed through a decision
about this but I'd be grateful Maybe by
new finance manager
but possibly maybe come to the climate
working group and to discuss or maybe
increasing renewable energy elements
that are
of our tariff
um given that we couldn't prepare to
find that emergency
item three public contribution so I
understand you've got James Jackson
speaking on the future of the different
benefits online
you'd like to come up to the you had to
come out to the sun here speaking of
them
[Music]
well it sounds a bit of a watch but
you've got three minutes but it only
starts being telling us through the
stopwatch
well uh thank you ladies and gentlemen
for giving me the opportunity
uh to speak this evening
um all the councilors have had an email
from me uh giving an idea of The
Proposal
that is to have the old Biddeford
Library
building which was a gift of the town
by the Carnegie foundation in 1900 or
thereabouts
and in parallel a chance to save
a very large collection of art books
together these
these have the potential to create
a unique cultural resource
and provide a boost to the hotel at the
same time
firstly
I must ask you to consider is this a
worthwhile project
um
um I I propose that this uh project if
it's acceptable we achieved at no cost
the tourist District Council uh due to
external funding
um
the other extra questions which might be
answered
are one
what would the cost be to tourist
District Council
if um
they wish to get this building into
shape
to consider it as a rental proposition
two
who would take it as an unrepaired site
um on a rental repair basis whilst there
are numerous less complicated uh options
available
please what are the costs
and social implications of living empty
who
or he was also asking what
qualifications and experience I have to
bring this project to a satisfactory
conclusion
now firstly I hold a diploma from the
chartered Institute of building
in building maintenance management and
also that I've worked as a general
manager in the industry
and secondly in 2011
I was tasked with um restoring or
refurbishing appledorn Library which was
then on the verge of closure by Devon
County Council
and is now considered one of the United
small libraries
in in county and probably in the whole
of the South
uh
furthermore I have exchange letters with
the Department of culture media and
Sport
and have passed these and consulted with
uh torrent storage voluntary services
in assembling bids
to achieve the uh the funding from
various institutions
uh I've also been promised ongoing
managerial support from a number of
number of directions
um
and although I've only been working on
this project for about two or three
weeks I've covered a lot of ground and
we've got a lot of uh verbal and and
written support
uh I've spoken with John Hart Who as you
probably know is the the leader of Devon
County Council
and um
he likes the project but uh would only
only um go into writing on the matter if
you felt that he wasn't upsetting
College District Council thank you
thank you Mr Jackson for that thank you
yeah
item four on agenda declarations
interest uh members view on all the
school there if you have an
interesting comes up please describe the
nature
[Music]
item five agenda agreement of agenda
items 102 the final part two items this
evening
the item six is do consider
correspondence or a business book or by
the direction of the chair I have known
okay January 7 is the joint protocol for
dealing with unauthorized encampments
Pages 18 to 44 before
thanks thanks Jay
um right so the this could be a short
report
um we've got to inspectors here from
Devon Cornwall please Sue sat in the the
audience there without any particular
questions in relation to the police side
of the protocol
um we were due to report this that the
last one can submitted but due to the
number of items on the agenda that we
did it was deferred until uh tonight
um so what we're looking at here is the
the working Arrangements the protocol
and the principles that would operate
between the district council and the
police should there be any unauthorized
incumbent on Irish District Council land
so we're only talking about the protocol
the district councils planned
um
this
somewhat restricted in terms of what we
were able to do principally because the
council doesn't have a Transit site or
tolerated trespass
prosperous side so in terms of power to
the district council part of the place
they are somewhat restricted than they
might otherwise be it this report isn't
about looking at uh any sites that they
should ask for a future discussion on
that they will come out of any future
review of our joints local plan and
they're all considered by the joints
planning policy committee
um
the papers there for discussion and or
agreements or the recommendation is to
approve the joint clinical between the
district council and Governor or police
interested
any urgent questions
[Music]
thank you
um I'm prepared to propose that we um we
accept the recommendation of this report
but perhaps I'm preempting any questions
that might want to be asked but I do
recommend this report to you it makes a
formal agreement it actually the
protocol itemizes exactly whose
responsibility what powers both the
district council have what powers the
police have to act and so it is clear
for all of us to understand that we're
not sitting on our hands not doing
anything but there are processes that we
follow and I think this will help when
we when and if
uh we have an encampment again
but it actually firms up the agreement
between us and the police and several
other districts are actually already
part of this protocol so I commend it to
you and I have to restart it
sorry yeah
um yes it's very full report can I ask
one thing on page 24
um section 1.9 uh police Powers will
only be used when the encampment is
having a significant impact such as
depriving a community of local amenities
clearly The Travelers in benefit did
that because Victoria Park is a local
amenity but then I see it 110 it says it
will be for the police to determine what
constitutes a significant impact
um God do we know who in the police
force actually decides this
questions
yes it's a very valid question isn't it
well I would say it's probably like a
couple points should be made is it
Southwest of debt and wide agreements
that will bring some consistency but
also because others are adopting it
they'll be learning and reviewing so we
can watch how it works in other areas
and apply that to those hopefully the
yearly with you to tweak it um it's
significant impact isn't phrase and it
goes on in the end is to give
so in the dependencies it does give some
sort of circumstances or conditions and
it does mention immediately right but it
does need to be that significant impact
so I think what we had is most of the
encampment on the Coach Park in areas of
some of it then on the fringes of the
football pitch but actually was not
significant put that in perspective I'm
not saying it hasn't had an impact I'm
just saying for that level of
significant impact compared to the place
where these Powers have been voted
previously recalled had the incident
where we had a large group go down the
a30 block the road lead Vehicles
abandoned in the road go on to cause
serious disruption serious crime a
number of service stations that was a
significant impact what we had to
measure is not just the fact that
they're on the premise of immunity but
also the level of crime is reported and
there was a disparency between what was
reported online and what we saw on
social media
came through to us which were very
different so it was a bit of rumor there
was some fact in in all sides but on the
basis of the police side of it I had two
crimes reported recording crimes which
were directly applicable that were ones
with actress and belongings from a park
bench which were recovered and the other
was an instant at service station so on
a police basis that's not significant
impact me is for inspector to make that
decision which was myself but there's a
protocol in there so that if there is a
disagreement and you know that you as a
council think that it is an impact then
we can escalate that between the sales
and it would go to maybe honestly as
Steve then
[Music]
I mean lots of Parish councils own
public playing spaces and car parts
where where elderly reported do they
report to Torres or the do they reported
straight to the police
um it's a responsibility of the parish
or term Council or the Sheamus forage
has its responsibility the owner of the
land and so
um
you'll be their responsibility to stay
there any Parish
we have powers for our own language not
for everybody else's so we go straight
to the face
yeah to show you a similar thing applies
you should be very similar process so
you need to seek um unusual powers
through the courts as a parish council
so seeking to apply to the magistrate
schools to enact those powers that you
have to the people of trespassing on
your land and then you would pursue
those powers like George did in this
case at the same time as we continually
Monitor and discuss whether it's
appropriate to use police powers and
I'll add to that you've got a um
is one thing to say the police have a
power the second is looking at the
logistics are actually doing that you
know we've got some very young families
some very young children by seeding you
know a caravan we remove somebody's home
those children house that's the
responsibility obviously which we have
so it's
um they're quite significant powers to
enact and the consequences of enacting
them are also very impacted when all
parties not just the police so it's
keeping that balance sure please
show your hand up yeah I was just
following up on the statement there were
only a couple of supports and crimes to
you
I wonder if that's partly because
um a lot of public
so for the reporting crimes because I
don't think they're going to have the
action and I was in touch with the
commercial manager of the Burton
about her actual experiences and what
happened
her response when we talked about what
happened habitat for the police have
been useless
I contacted them through 101 on Ryan's
Saturday afternoon but have had no
response even though I provided mobile
number for when the building was closed
we had an instant account today which
was the mundane so I called 101 I was
told to attempt from the queue if you
have any more trouble whilst on the
phone please hang up and call 999
that's what 999 was called just before
3pm as youth were running around
buildings swearing our customers and
attempting to send off the fire alarm
they did not attend
a locked on left building 4 30 PM having
had no contact in police they left the
car part a patrol car drove past button
heading towards to keep it at Non-Stop
so yeah there's a lot of stuff on social
media
and people say oh we haven't had
official reports that might be why I'd I
agree that there's a few things at play
there's an apathy in in reporting and
there's some issues with our 101 system
and online reporting
and and potentially 999 now I can't
I'm not going to pretend that there are
not issues with the contact center
um things have improved they have got
better they put a lot more resource for
it but I I get the fact it's incredibly
frustrating but also we from from My
Level you know I cannot act on
information that I don't know how I
can't even monitor a social media site
such as a local Facebook page unless
I've got specific reason for going in to
look at specific item number evidence I
need to apply for an authority to do
that so I can't even scrutinize
you know social media to see if a report
might not come in until it's come to our
notice by other means so as frustrating
as it is I can only act on the
information that's been reported to us
we have got the storage email address as
well which is online to go online type
in your neighborhood it will bring up
the contact details of the local team
here in Biddeford and our local email
inbox and obviously if it's a crime in
progress don't report it but if you've
reported something online and you want
to make my team aware of it then you can
use that online facility to contact us
but if people dial 999 don't get a
response I wonder how many people
imagine they're taking trouble
they're reported to some form online
yeah and I agree and that's where the
app he's in but unfortunately is fears
of influence I can't fix the 999 system
control room I dearly wish it works
better
briefly following up on your early point
if that's the case should the protocol
not actually include not only the
district and city
um authorities but shouldn't it cover up
all local authorities including the town
councils and the county councils at the
moment this seems to be specific just to
the higher level District Etc
um a huge amount of of land is that
publicly owned land in this district is
not in bidified or normal
um
okay because Steve probably stopped me
if I'm wrong but I think the the a is
the first time we've got a protocol
agreed on a definite basis so I think
the hope would be that that can be
worked out unfortunately it's not only
if we get
um an authorizing cabinet again it's
when it will happen so it will get put
to the test we learned from other areas
and I'd hope that you're going to seek
to expand that and become agreed with
the you know the towns and parishes what
I would hope would work is we all work
together is if you had an unauthorized
encampment on a rugby pitch over by the
parish that you could be guided through
that legal process by district with the
support of the police and we work
collectively together by the terms and
principles like protocol because the
same branding cards are available you
just might not have the same ready
access the legal support and structure
of going through that process which may
be exceeds has no experience of it was
something that the deputy leader and
leader of myself and other members said
to you are talking about and and really
when you go back to your parishion town
councils you need to make them aware of
their responsibilities and you know as
uh
offer support
um the likelihood is it tends to be
tempted around a bit of original
location
predominantly anyway
um
um sorry it's great that you're playing
with protocol in in place for
unauthorized companies but surely you
should not put them more urgency being
touched to actually finding a vehicle
site so that this protocol would be a
very secondary thing that would be
happening and we've had legal powers to
um
I mean just to mention that you know
within us we're going to talk about it
we're going to talk about it there's an
accident that's going to be the next
meeting
why not why not man why is there more
urgency attached when obviously that
that's huge numbers
um and I know um Peter couldn't have
suggested that there's such a normal
clothes that has the water was singing
Whatever and I appreciate that that is
actually a North Devon
um thing not hours and therefore some
negotiation may even meant to be um you
know
done about that but surely the urgency
the thing these people need somewhere to
be able to come you can go without
annoying everybody upsetting everybody
surely that is the most urgent thing
that we should address
sooner rather than later
okay sorry Professor Brunton thank you
um yes
so I presume that we've just said that
there's like program conference and I
tend to agree with you that the policy
that you use this time of gentle
persuasion I don't know what you've
called it because obviously a
significant um is open to terribly
interpretation or it sounds like a woman
in the Burton but didn't see it as
anything but a really serious threat and
intimidating Behavior so I I suggest
that there's some kind of negotiating
officer who can actually study
um how you deal with this sort of unawat
behavior and I totally agree with your
approach because there were the other
children there I mean we saw that when
we went down they were nappies on the
line and that sort of thing you know
definitely were very young two of them
there as well as these news but um I do
think that we need to have some kind of
negotiating process with these um
uh with Travelers so that we can have
straight away have a liaison with them
to persuade those who aren't holding a
crime which you didn't think they were
but others did
um so we're going to encourage them in
either a short time as possible and to
obey as many of these social regulations
that you'd like everybody else to you
know so the protocol based on working
practice
[Music]
couldn't agree I couldn't agree on the
side
of it would be in the last Council and
they couldn't agree on the site and of
course if they had none of this would
have been necessary
so yeah so the protocol as as trading is
um document was very much what was
followed in essence by both the district
council news so same to those
individuals arrived who went down and
met them we insisted them jointly to
ascertain where they come from their
intentions and how long they're going to
stay what they're going to do see if
they're going to engage now different
groups um their factions infections of
different groups engage in different
ways actually this week engage quite
positively but that's from the adult
perspective
um some immediate requests were laid
down about you know being the complexity
to the nurseries the dogs not being kept
on leads but In fairness when we've gone
down and then Revisited we've also then
tied up vehicles have been moved
um so it's a constant case of Engagement
because if you get that engagement wrong
then actually you can trigger behaviors
which are far more impacted on the
community because it's very easy for
them to just not engage at all
and not assist with that process so
it was a matter of the setting that
working together and whilst they did
seem to be probably not directly if
they're using the bins which were
provided they're starting things up and
it's not ideal you know and and I forget
the fact that people don't want it but
it will happen and we do have sat in the
background of diverse community theme we
give a lot of advice on this and very
directly with those groups
um and every time one of these incidents
is created it's very carefully recorded
by ourselves City making and we engage
with that diverse communities sergeant
and staff who can direct us about what
we know about the group without them
before and the best ways in engaging
with them is that's very much what what
effectively patient but this is just
getting it out West there's no confusion
about how long the Sims page and what
happens I have and what order they
should appear
foreign
[Music]
thank you chair well I did take the
trouble to read all 25 pages of this
protocol at home
um
it's a very wordy document it's about
too too much
words in there that will be supported
then
okay councilor Newton said why if she
didn't include marriage internal
councils it should have done
but what I wanted to ask was that the
chocolate page 31
it does speak at the local Authority uh
their powers that they can give a
direction and I I always understood this
to be the case direction to leave the
land and then it is in advance to fail
to comply with such a direction there
my question isn't Steve will answer this
at all did we issue a direction for them
to leave alone all I saw as dancers with
them oh to go to the magistrates court
it's up to the magistrates Court when
they're here any application well that's
all I was told that's all parents were
told
there may have been exaggeration on
social media I don't use social media so
I wouldn't know but to hear what's just
been reported about the issues in the
burden
and to see the affair actually they'll
stick them left the park because of the
issues that they obviously must have
been experiencing they came back later
on so my question is did we issue that
direction for them to leave them alone
or not
um there's Direction issued on the
Monday following their arrival arrived
on Tuesday afternoon as Inspector
mentioned we have to go through a
process so housing officers property
team have to meet an early age with them
clearly if we had a tolerated trespass
site uh then you can start that process
much sooner and much quicker because
you've identified somewhere where the
council's willing to tolerate them to
settle employing period of time in the
absence of that as I said earlier the
powers are much more limited and then
we're Reliant if the case may be on
um excessive anti-social Behavior to
start that early process which clearly
has has been uh here tonight's wasn't
the case so that process was then
started I think an email went around to
all counselors on Monday and I think
Wednesday
[Music]
so equally a good start process we still
reliant on Port and obviously when we
when you go to the court you've got to
have evidence and reason uh trust that
Travelers can move from an unauthorized
place so if you've got somewhere to move
them to that obviously helps that comes
to a Brenton mentioned earlier in
responsibility Council of Avail a number
of sites have been brought forward over
the past couple of years
thus far
yeah just briefly
that they just say onset directions
that is an offense to fail to comply
with it
talking about evidence for what he
wanted to move now they're into there in
this Direction that's it and they don't
leave it's illegal
once you get that through the court
process so had they not had The
Travelers Not moved by the Wednesday
assuming the course had granted the the
notice then that would become an offense
at that point
not what that says here
well thank you very much so it's been
proposed by Professor Hudson I believe
the second reference
[Music]
I'm sure has always
against
the extensions
[Music]
of course
thank you very much
sure that was 28 4 and three of
sanctions thank you very much
working groups and Pages 45 to 46 on
your agenda
and chief executive assistant
thanks don't share uh probably a bit in
this straightforward uh so this is to
appoint an additional member to the
harbor board
um increasing the number of members on
the Harbor board and appointing a
further member I believe the leaders
thank you chair I would hold my hand up
and say
I got it slightly wrong at the last
meeting I I'd asked canister Brenton to
do it and I had two last minute
additions put to me and I'm sitting with
the last minute
editions and I did forget cancer Brenton
I don't know how I managed it forget it
obviously I did so I'd like to move the
recommendation we have the number to Six
and the second recommendation as I
recommend it David Council veteran does
join the harmful committee exactly
perhaps it every second right all in
favor please show
and he goes
13 characters
um
this report they'll say three working
groups they're actually the last four
times we've decided to set up the uh
water working good parties
group actually and it's not one like
this so we're using a policy now with
the council so I'll presume it we'll be
there okay that was a task and finish
group rather than a working group within
the Constitution for that probably not
sure have been such in order
thank you moving on then to item nine uh
the Strategic Plan update which is made
of 47-53 on your agenda and once again
the executive
ably assistable as a leader because of
James School presented
uh thanks chair I'm sure they'll need a
lot of uh some points to make in a
second
um so this is now all members have been
appointed to different committees lead
member roles etc etc
um it's time that we start considering
uh your vision your strategic plan of
what you want to deliver what you want
to achieve over the next four years
during your your term of office
um it's you know it it is timely so
we've got
um a session a workshop scheduled for
Monday the 14th of August another the
leaders emails or members uh with the
dates and details around that including
a short survey so we've had eight
responses so far so can we have the
other 28 please uh we still wanted to
chase up uh response in to acceptance or
not attending the workshop on the 40s
and it's important that we can Clarity
of company members are going to turn out
if they're nothing else that we don't
waste any food on the lunch but clearly
we want as many members there as as
possible I understand it's it's August
and it will be on possibly on holidays
or away particularly there's a really
really important item and a really
important session
uh so the the report uh says folks are
just kind of brief timetable on page 48
uh with tonight being the launch uh
Monday the 14th be in your Workshop
where we want you to engage and give us
that uh
Asian Direction
moving on to a full council meeting in
mid-september toward the beginning of
October we're with collate all the
information you've provided us with uh
so that we can prepare reports to go to
consultation there are stakeholders
communities residents town and Parish
councils can give their views on the
things she wants to receive in the
Australia plan for the coming year years
uh then with a view of running a
consultation for a six-week period up
until the end of November and bring in
all of that information back before you
before the end of the calendar year and
um
11th of December that'll enable then
your officer team to start developing uh
business cases for each of the services
between that point and up to the end of
the financial year of March 24 and
clearly then natural evolve into a
quarterly Business Report which is uh
reported on a broadly basis to internal
order and Student News
I've highlighted in the report that 2020
themes the the vision so local economy
communities health and housing our
environment our future and our Council
so we're asking are they the right
things are there other things or other
themes you want to add
um I think it's only right to point out
um we already have a a work program
carried over from the the last council
with some significant uh projects in to
the development of a new environment
Center the Apple door being Maritime
Innovation Center uh delivering all the
funding through the shared Prosperity
schemes and depending on tonight's
division later on uh development and
implementation of like some housing and
modular units to deal with our temporary
accommodation and performance issues
um I've highlighted some of the more
strategic things that the council are
aware of and things you may need to
consider as part of your uh drawing up
your vision so I'm sure you're all aware
of the the opportunities around floating
offshore wind
um x-links so those clean energy uh type
of projects
Devolution uh the potential
opportunities that might give this
Council along with the other districts
and unitaries within
and finally as we picked up during the
induction we've been
highlighted as a council
um for leveling up partnership
we don't know the the full details of
that yet other than this 400 million
across the current across the country
the 20 uh such councils we've been
identified because of our percentage of
our adults with level three plus called
patients or gvi gva per hour worked
medium gross weekly pay and health life
expectancy that's not to say they're
good uh metrics the metrics are that we
need leveling up so they're the kinds of
things you need to be thinking of what
as we develop are switching line
um it wouldn't be it'd be remissioning
not to mention uh funding
um as we've talked about local
government and budget and in finance and
budgets so that's obviously one of the
barriers uh potentially
um looking at the the duration of the
Strategic line we've historically had
that on a four-year basis to run for
every term of office
um because of the length of some of
these strategic projects it proposed we
have a longer term behaviors that's
updated on a rolling basis
foreign
[Music]
it's all very clear in the report
um a couple of things I go to highlight
is this is your
strategic now and then it can only
happen if you're there on the day and
obviously we need to know numbers and
also it'd be nice to have a much better
return on the um the survey that's
attached to it
um
in some ways you know this is quite
exciting because not only have we got
the big schemes that we're already doing
the Marine Center and there's an awful
lot going on with that and the
Environmental Center we were joking
earlier we're not sure which plan we're
on in the moment with the Environmental
Center hopefully we're on the final plan
um and also the level and up Fund in
this uh three weeks episode it's a
double-edged sword we're getting the
money because we're in a deprived area
that's nothing to be particularly proud
of because why we're at a private area
and that's down to us as members to
drive it forward and we're responsible
to our families we should be making sure
that we're not at a quiet area so we've
got the opportunity I don't want to go
into all the details I think when we
come to doing it on the day I think we
can explain much more
um and it will be more relevant when we
actually come in to explain that
um but I've said to those who said they
can't come I think if you look at the
um if you look at the timetable in
particular
we need to have something that can go to
the ministry at the end of March this is
what we're being told or to 11 and up
Department we'll also gain some advice
they'll probably be better to be aiming
for the end of the year so we we've
moved forward the September nation into
August and then you can see the layout
that we just about got it in at the end
of the year and able to get work
prepared for March
we would look so a lot silly if we don't
get this moving and we don't get a
chance to get that money
um and not only that we would be letting
down on that our communities I'm not
going to have to see that happen so we
will do that what I will say those who
can't make the day there will be
follow-up reports and a chance for
people to have their views to that
before so it will be all 36 I hope those
who've been on the coast as long as they
have will remember we just have these
meetings and then when you enter full
Council for adoption some would stand up
and say well I wasn't there on that day
I don't approve of it
I would much prefer we deal with it on
the day and we get the input there will
be some that can't and I accept that as
well
um so I would go to just keep it simple
and record a proposal recommendations we
know the report and the timetable which
I think is really important and we do
look at how our strategic plan has got
some longevity because some of these
plans will go way before the four years
and Way Beyond the five years that we
need to plan for this community what
we're going to deliver and this is for
me Isn't serious but it's a golden
opportunity
for people to come let us know about the
life parts of the um questionnaire and
let's show that our community that we're
serious about delivering something to
improve this portal report really in
some ways that we qualified because of
Declaration
okay thank you thank you
um
wishes to
um support that
back in that motion and he also wishes
to speak what we've got Council Thomas
and his number first
just don't need our work programs I'll
put this with the environment Center
I've spoken to Richard Payson I've seen
the plans
and what appears to be planned at the
moment is officers workshops and parking
for all the waste and refuge vehicles
I think calling it an environment Center
smacks a little bit of green watching
it's not an environment center it's a
decade
office
for the uh he also and itself obviously
I think for a number of reasons
Financial being with only one and it's
now been scaled back a little bit more
has been good kids described so perhaps
that needs to be looked at in future
yeah right God just reply to that I
would agree with you it did start over
it's an environmental center because we
wanted to deal with recycling recycling
is a really up and down business
um we're getting quite a good deal
through Coastal that was just spent uh
awful lot of money in Exeter and are
Keen to take our recycling but we were
getting to the stage where we couldn't
deliver anything the wish lists have
just got so big it was going to be all
or nothing so we have paired it back a
little bit and the reason we've paired
it back is part of the reason is two
reasons really is what is whilst middle
dock is concerned which is the main base
for the law is we need for the
environment for the Marine Innovation
Center and we need to get on with that
otherwise we'll be losing that money and
the other one is the workshops are up at
um and I always go to Facebook on but
anyway
the workshops are
is Victorian building it is awful
conditions for us staff to be working in
this stage so we needed to look at the
budget we needed to look what we must
get on and provide and as I say that the
recycling
economically probably at the next at the
moment it's better to do a deal with
um Coastal however there is land there
that we could look at could more funding
become available but we couldn't deliver
the whole package you know I won't go
into the frequency but it was getting
almost ridiculous and we've come back to
what we budgeted for in the first place
so we can crack on with the Marines
Furniture we can get our manager bad
conditions
and it should be a win-win and we've
spent years on it construction and the
others would know we have gone London
though looking precise we've just about
secured the site and it will deliver
what we need at the at this moment what
we do in the future again would depend
on funding so I hope that
answers
that's a question yes I'd like to second
that
um a couple of things I would add on
page 49 you've briefly mentioned the
opportunities
for consideration uh the floating
optional wind
um this is in my paper today I mean I
hadn't heard of
um apparently Mark great for the first
minister of Wales and Linda Taylor the
leader of Cornwall
a signing agreement about the Celtic uh
offshore wind
um we seem to be there's there's no
mention of torridge at all it's just
four more miles which is slightly
worrying uh the second Point x-links
well I turned up to the presentation
here our economic uh officers by the
north Devon and the toroid one they
already seem to have embraced this from
what I saw but it's all good stuff
um the third one Devolution can we have
an updated report where we have this
meeting at a fortnight because I read on
social media the opposition at County
Hall and various other places the
evolution is a dead duck I'll be
interested to hear that no need to
discuss it now I'm just asking for
report up to date we'll get it one other
thing I will say about the leavening up
fund
um our mayor in Biddeford assures us
the Jackie Cox is going to attend our
Council meetings and wants to talk about
leveling up
are there any other councils want to
come and hear him but uh I'm not sure
when it's going to be but we're assured
that he's coming
well seriously
tell me on Thursday
that's not on the agenda
yeah
that's my understanding
okay once I hear all the questions has
been proposed and has been secondary
support
you know insurance
very much thank you Steve
and then moving on to item 10 on your
agenda updating the north Devon and
toric Super Plan and the receiver report
from the planning manager of Alex Smith
and the enrollments
it's all written down on lunchroom
good evening members and thank you chair
so the the report is item 10 and at
their Pages 5461 of your agenda
um and you'll see the purpose of the
report is set out and to consider the
approach to undertaking an update
the north Devon and Toyota plan and just
just briefly a list of background and
indeed much of the background is set out
in your report and also I think most of
you attended the recent local plan
Workshop briefings which went into some
more detail about
where we've been the journey we've been
on over the past
certainly in the past sort of 18 months
to two years and so we're not going to
go over that in detail and the local
plan was adopted in October 2018 as most
of you will know
um in December of 2020 the full councils
of both torridge and all seven
council's resolved to move forward with
a comprehensive review of The Joint
local plan
um main reasons for this were due to a
change in context at this time
um changes to local priorities the the
impact of covid
and the housing crisis and also the
importance of um the climate and
ecological emergency so they were some
of the driving forces at that time for
embarking on a comprehensive review
and the commencement of that competitive
review was initially delayed again due
to Hiatus around the covert pandemic
work started sort of in Earnest in
summer 2021 and this was an early
evidence Gathering
confirmation of governance arrangements
and also just general project planning
the first meeting of the the newly
formed joint planning policy committee
took place in early 2022 now as most
members will be aware the role of the
joint planning policy committee is
essentially delegated authority for
pretty much all local plan matters with
the exception of approving or not formal
adoption ability that will always come
back to full hands or
um formal program was agreed a local
development scheme and the people in
place project and branding was
established followed by a soft launch in
March 2022. I'll just hand over to Ian
who will just summarize what happens
after that
good evening chair good evening members
yeah so in the summer of 2022 officers
were tasked with reflecting on the
approach to updating the local plan and
whether or not so comprehensive update
remained to be the most necessary remain
necessary and appropriate now in
particular this came around from uh
considering the local government Finance
situation and the more challenging
perspective on that aspect of it and
also emerging National planning reforms
that were somewhat uncertain at that
point between time
in the second half of 2022 in response
to that we carried out an extensive
program of work to understand the
performance of the existing plan and the
potential consequences of the context
and the way of updating it
we parent out technical appraisal of the
plan using planning advisory service
plan review toolkits we had a program
engagements with your sales and
selective members and we engage with
external professional support through
plant who advisory Service as a critical
friend
now the outcome of that work was that
broadly speaking the plan was Upstate
and fit for purpose and a few aspects of
it were out of Conformity with national
planning policy but that they could
generally be managed to our development
management processes
now there was some sort of some
uncertainty about National planning
before remaining at that point in time
and there was uncertainty about how we
demonstrated our fiber housing land
Supply or not
um however there was clearly aspects of
the plan were no longer aligned with
member aspirations as well and that was
that was a key driver for reflecting on
the planet
so joint planning policy committee
result in January 2023 to recommend to
move the targeted partial update of the
local plan and to recommend that to each
of the food councils at North Devon and
storage and the detailed recommendations
put forward at that point are provided
an appendix one to your report on page
61 of your agenda and it is worth being
mindful of those
full council at North Devon resolved to
follow the jppc recommendations at the
end of January 2023 and move to that
partial update
all council at torridge considered a
comparable report but resorted to defer
that decision and seek further
information from joint planning policy
committee on the potential scope of that
particle update that was referred back
to doing planning policy committee uh
who met in March 2023
the outcomes of that was uh set out at
paragraph 2.7 of your report on page 55
of the agenda and the identified a
narrow scope of what could be achieved
for a partial updates the main aspects
being first homes which is a housing
product from the government which is not
covered in our existing local plan it
was introduced after that
the potential for introducing some small
sites for additional housing through
allocations uh to help some of our small
medium Enterprise local builders that
was something that was identified as a
potential issue and something that
members would like to follow uh
reviewing our tourism policies around
attractions and accommodation and seeing
what we could do with those to make it
more enabling our rural economy policy
Coastal change and food field change
Management areas work we had ongoing
sites for travelers very topical this
evening
and some climate change considerations
such as onshore wind or looking at
targeted policy changes and guidance
but we would not be able to look to
fundamentally alter any strategies or
fundamentally alter any approaches to
any of those types of matters and we
would end up at the same base note for
2031 with our plan
so the four kinds of recommendations
talk for a report to be returned in
April of this year we were unable to do
that because of the emerging and
upcoming local elections
and subsequent meetings of this full
Council have full of universe and have
focused on establishing the council
government governance around League
members Etc
but it's not been possible to bring a
report until today without handling back
to Helen at this point Thank you thank
you so um just to conclude the report
before you were school council today is
is seeking members guidance and
direction for officers
um to take with regard to an update to
the local plan
um it is worth reflecting on on the
current context it has circumstances
have changed again since
um this matter was previously considered
we have a new Council
um you you as a council may have your
own your own aspirations and just on the
previous item I had a briefing on your
strategic planning day and specifically
some key projects that are are coming
forward and emerging and potentially
transformational opportunities there are
before North Devon and courage districts
at the moment and these are set out in
paragraphs um 2.10 to 2.12 will report
consistent with some of the ones raised
by the most notably middle dock for
leveling up partnership floating
offshore wind X links and more widely
green economy and Associated supply
chain opportunities the existing local
plan I think it's important to note that
there is potentially support for those
for those projects but I think it's the
members to to consider whether as a
council you wish to be proactive or
reactive to those opportunities as they
come forward
um there are still a range of
uncertainties the five-year housing land
Supply and the position that was
confirmed at the end of April but both
councils consider that they can
demonstrate how demand Supply however
this is currently being challenged
through a planning appeal which um has
been going on within Northern District
but that could have an impact on the
status of the local plan and National
planning reforms a consultation
commenced last week on
a raft of proposed changes
um it's still somewhat unknown in terms
of scope and timings of those and making
and the approach to plan making does one
part of that consultation
um which is running until the 18th of
October and officers will be going
through all of those in detail and still
reviewing at the moment the consequences
of that consultation where it may end up
um so to conclude there's not a clear
black and white or binary option for you
all it's hence it's an open
recommendation to you
um for you as members to determine what
you consider to be the most appropriate
approach to updating the local plan
there is
um the recommendation from jpbc which is
as Ian said set out in appendix one of
this agenda item and that is to move to
a targeted parcel update as a purpose
scope set out on the report There's an
opportunity to hurry after comprehensive
update and effectively prepare a new
local plan or alternative it's open to
members to to resolve something
different still and the recommendation
is set out of paragon 5.1 of your report
and whatever is resolved or determined
this evening will go back to the next
generally VPC meeting which will be the
first meeting on of the new councils and
we do recognize it as a complex subject
happy to take any questions or about any
points clarification
um and I just like through the chat
according to the league though I believe
would like to say a few words
like my view is very simple
the new Council it's new opportunities
and why are we tinkering with a policy
that started in 28 2008 was agreed in
2018 in 2019 we had a new Council we
went to jpp sign which is and well we
went to the working groups there wasn't
jpbc though the idea of the jppc was
that rather than working with keep
coming back to full council with
suggestions I was going to sold on what
ideas I think if you're doing something
that everybody is responsible for we
have a responsibility to come back to
all members however it was decided to
enabled escaping joint planning policy
committee
um in 2019 we started to look at as a
working group what was in the program
and immediately there was a lot of alarm
bells ringing about how a date it was
and then we were just the doctor so
consequently in 2020
um Note 7 under us went to full Council
and said we need a full review
they're obviously in between we have
covered and everything else that came
along and it just sort of got
I wouldn't say on the back burner but we
couldn't deal with it so we moved on a
little bit
um I know we're in a position where a
partial reveal would have been possible
probably last year we are now getting
very near to when we need to do a new
local plan
and common sense to me and and I know
most of you don't agree with my
compensation but it does indicate that
if we've got to have a new plan by 2031
we've got a period of time to do it why
are we spending time and resources on
doing a partial review which can't
change
strategic policy we can only do
adjustment to what we've already got
whereas we really need to be looking at
does it Supply the fundamentals of what
we're doing so the world's moves on
rapidly in the last two to three years
the results are covered working from
home technology I know we're into a
position where we've just been talking
about we're a deprived area
so what are we going to do about it are
we just going to look at the old plan
and say we're Tinker with it or are we
going to be a bit more Brave a bit more
adventurous and say what can we do with
the local plan to deliver now in the
background I'm sorry this will come out
muddled because that's how I work is
that we've got Devon Futures that is
North Devon porridge and petrol looking
at what we can do in terms of skills
employment and stuff like that in the
area and it's being suggested that some
of that will not fit the existing plan
we need to look forward we've now got
they're leveling up
um partnership which has given us huge
opportunities to go forward as an area
and what we should be saying is what
plan do we need to be able to deliver
them what we don't want to be doing is
tinkering around the edges and then
discover them we can't deliver what we
want to do so I've banged this wrong and
that's popular in some areas but it's
found some concerns a new Council it's
new opportunities let's just get our
brains around what we can deliver to our
community
um and so my recommendation is is that
full council tonight that we go for a
full review
um I won't go into some of the details
about financing all I can say is I think
we're okay on that side I won't go into
Staffing and I think it went more than
okay on that side
there might be issues in other areas but
on those and I mean geographically other
areas or areas within this Council so I
would recommend that we vote tonight we
go for a full review we refer it back to
jppc in a Titanic several meetings
recently I expect members to turn up to
JP's PC meters the only reason we ended
up with a partial one was because not
all our members turned up were a small
government are given voting points for
doing it make sure all stubborn of
theirs turned up and voted the way that
they wanted to go
we had a little bit about Fiasco is that
not all of us turned up one left early
and then because some of them some of
ours haven't been to the pre-meters they
weren't overshore what they were voting
for that it's not going to happen this
time I can assure you
um is that we are really going to get
this back together we're a good Council
we're going somewhere we've got the
funding to do it so my lead to all of
you is let's get on with a full review
we've got to do one anyway so let's get
on and do it and offer our community a
future of what we can deliver with the
funding available
before he leaves
told something yeah they did say yes it
was models
I'll just come back a minute as I said
it's all in my head
um we are not looking at a review as
such it will be a full new local plan
and it will be your plan or our plan
whichever way you want to look at it but
it will be a full new plan and and the
reason for that is we can't deal with
some of the stuff in the old even if we
review it or Tinker with it it's my
favorite one is at the moment is that we
can't change strategic plans we can only
Tinker around the edges so we're going
for a full new local plan just to be
absolutely clear I'll answer any other
questions if they're mine yeah so what
happens then if tonight we toriage
agreed to a full
um review and all Devin visit
accountable step there he was in and
only want to do a partial review do we
go our separate ways no longer be a
joint plan I've I had that discussion
recently with uh the chief exec and
they're probably lessons and I'd like to
see what I've got to say I've always
wanted that to Scotland last Monday
after the meeting we had it in the town
hall with the new leader of um North
Devon I would say that he is
aimable to our aims what he does want is
for me to go back to him and say this is
what we're doing and this is going to be
the advantages for North Devon because
what we've got to imagine when we're
doing all this funding and we're doing
the um
well the um the one with North Devon and
petrock Devon Futures Northern Devon
Futures is that
deep pollution is mentioned and I'm
quite happy to explain that because soon
it's not quite as black as he's painted
but new members and new policies have
always muddy the water a little bit
but if we're going to succeed is
Northern Devlin we have got to work
together and that is whilst I'm giving
North Devon a bit of a hard time
that has got to be our own because when
you look at the Devolution if you're
looking at all by Dema County
that's where a lot of the money is and
in the voting system that's where a lot
of the club is so we need to be United
with North Haven and I'm hoping that I
can sell that to them what I need is
your support to throw that we're all on
board on this on our side you haven't
really answered my question if they
don't agree do we go alone
we could do but my aim is to ensure that
we don't have to
negotiations are all about what we want
and what they want and in Devon Futures
there has been a slightly weakening
um conclusion that to to propel Northern
devil Futures forward we may need to do
a new local plan and I would say North
Denver involved in that side of it as
well and on the other side you know
um on the 11 and up
partnership deposits find the end at
college that have no shadow that there
will be overlapping if we're successful
the other side of the river should be as
well and and you know if we look at
Poland and wolf you look at um the
Marine Center this is all the stuff that
will drive the whole area forward so
I've got to go back and convince them
that it's good for them as well as it's
good for us
um if we have to do all of them yes we
will to remember
yeah
I would like the second uh the uh
proposal I think we ought to lead North
Devon into the future rather than follow
them
yeah I did see you yeah yes sir those
two other hands up first president
anyway
thank you um
yes or no answer
um that was abandoning the present Burke
of burn in any way affects the leveling
up money that we're hoping to achieve in
in the near future no we won't abandon
the local time that will stay in place
until we get the new one in Paris so we
will carry on where we are
[Music]
is that
we get policies turning at us and money
sometimes that's my kind of riding alley
and can you do it on Monday so what we
need to do is to build some of the city
I've seen for the new local plane and we
can deal with it and we've already
talked earlier about having a strategic
and having a slightly longer paragraph
but we can
we can do what we can do I'm hoping that
once we get into the new local fund
there will be material consideration so
as we develop the policies we want to do
that we do not look at how that new plan
is develop any benefits I've got to be
able to do I will be doing it on the
open system that when he may be able to
um use that as a material situation if
we need to right I think it actually
just be a positive approach
thank you
[Music]
technically we can start it from next
autumn having November but we believe
that God is just need a leading time to
that and then from that day on we've
only got 13 months with Peter whereas if
you think of the last one took 10 years
and a few days actually over the 10
years
um but this one quite tight time scale
because it comes back to this album
though is
it would be lovely to be updated you
learn it but you can't do that because
the world is changing so quickly you
know we never thought without code but
we never thought we'd been working from
home and all those small things so if we
can get it at all offices
don't put them under pressure to do
something that's not going to benefit us
really work on where we want to be the
next Autumn when we start to live in the
new local time in a form of working form
so that we've only got 30 months to
actually deliver it you know and that
brings effective on
um
just up to about 27 and then you know if
I have a new plan in 31 anyway so let's
be in front of the game not get to 3031
I think what we're going to do we're
still working on the plan we started on
in 2011. so that is rough year because
especially the starting is in the Autumn
we want to start gathering information
of those and then we've got 30 months to
deliver it I think
yeah I'll be working hard he thinks the
opposite work yeah there is the
consultation that's running well
we have to respond
ing process regardless
there will there will be a need to
updates yeah and prepare a new level
plan in the medium term in any case at
the very least and we can't have
opposition two at the same time
thank you
two speakers aside consider another just
get cancer to be first thank you Chad
yeah I've never ever over the last
month's
wondered why we were even considering
doing a partial review
the current local plan is broadband well
it is in Conformity with the nppf in
most respects
why we why we haven't decided that we
might do a part of you it was beyond me
and I never supported that view
I do agree that a joint Plumbing noise
then is not is what we should be doing
because I think it's been very
successful and there's a lot of overlap
between orange and North again very
similar issues so I would hope a joint
plan a new joint plan
will read received a supportive of no no
democracy but um
those of us on the plans committee over
the last four years and currently having
cancer the local agreed on occasions and
the officers as well we really
struggled in some respects with certain
aspects of some of the policy and this
is why we do need an employment now
things change things have changed the
better deal over the last four or five
years so we do need an income and it
just does not make sense to spend
thousands their parents fingering around
the edges of some of the policies when
you can't alter the Strategic ones
why do that money into starting now
the work that we'll need to is having a
new plan and let's be able again and I'm
sure
the north stem Council will come on
board I really hope they do we've got
the officers here who can do it
um we're very lucky with our planning
office and the officers we've got I mean
they've just won that well inset but
maybe won that River in the south west
so that's that's not the name to get on
with a new a new plan
thank you
chair just to follow up and slightly
different from coach to another
I've spoken to somebody in North Devon
um today actually uh mostly show which
is interesting that somebody would come
from North Devon to lose the show but it
could obviously something foreign
000 people The Joint plan is seven
members from each side and having been
the substitute for the last six months
of the last credit so because people
weren't turning up I've been pretty well
stitched up by North Devon I got the
feeling of a bad feeling between the two
pencils and I'd mean that you being
recording this tip tonight but I'm a
little bit concerned that if we put
pressure on then North Denver might say
well we should have more seats than
porridge I I would be a bit nervous by
putting too much pressure on North Devon
for them to change their policy when I
was substitute and they were so strongly
in favor of the partial fan and I wonder
what strategies our leadership and I'm
not on the joint planning committee any
longer but I do do have real
hey the feelings that this could break
difficulty if we tried to enforce what
we want against the wishes of what North
Devon want I wonder if our leaders could
tell us how they plan to challenge that
I'm quite happy to answer them you are
on the hermetics and substitute it's
just not going to be available for a few
weeks but you are one of the two
substitutions I appreciate bill because
I'm determined that we always get the
right number
um
and the commentary was set up as it was
it was set up by Sean Harrington it's
worked in some ways
um it will work actually as long as our
members turn up and we get a proper vote
I don't that's not them go to me at all
um I've had discussions with the new
leader of North Devon and as I said
earlier I think I'm quite happy I can
work with the leader um in room
um and what he's saying to me is broken
I shown that there is the benefit
whether the sheer factors time is now
running up and when we made that initial
decision we would do well I never made
it so I spoke against it and I voted
against doing a partial with him and I
thought changed my view
um unfortunately it didn't go that way
that's democracy
um but no I feel we've got a Chancellor
with new councils on both sides with the
changing circumstances you know we've
got devil Futures trying to provide old
skills and education and some of you
will know that Hedgehog will go to go to
university over the next 10 years this
is an opportunity for our young people
this is a you've got to go away and earn
a job again get an education get a good
job and come back when you can afford to
live here those days are gone or they
should be gone and it's our job to make
sure they're gone is that we need to be
saying to our young people stay in the
area you can get first class education
at Petrol they are tankering 10
requires aim in their degrees at the
stuff we're providing like the Marine
Center and The Innovation Center
um and then we've got the skills board
that's working separate to college which
includes summer college
um really looking at how we can develop
skills and engine employ people and
we've got this leveling up partnership
which hopefully will give us a
considerable amount of money to actually
lift the area you know and I'm afraid
if we undone with some proposals and
we're told it doesn't fit the existing
local plan
I am not going to be happy and I would
expect all of our members not to be
happy that this is a chance you know
it's been described as a chance in a
lifetime and all that sort of stuff
we will know when we get that at the end
but the first thing is make sure we've
got a local plan that will enable us to
deliver all these options make sure it's
a local plan that actually takes into
consideration while communities want
rather than necessary this poetundant
you know we're being told we're getting
new uh a new policy a wide risk called a
News election on some of the lovely plan
on the planning stuff on the people you
know the mppf we were told we were going
to get in the spring well look outside
it's still so the winter now and we're
still waiting for some of it so
be on the front toy be positive get this
back to jppc make sure we got seven
votes and say this is a great
opportunity for Northern Devon
but the other things that go around it
will benefit the holding Northern Devon
and let's just get on with the job okay
I can't be doing this tinkering really I
don't want to be tinkering and I know
I've been told not to use that word but
that's how it feels thank you okay I
answered you somewhere along the line
yeah give me a live answer completely
thank you very much
it was a long time ago
and that's a short House
of recommendation people said well the
recommendation is that the people for a
comprehensive new local plan correct
okay
all in favor please Sean yeah
should we let this be unanimous
they'd be on the phone in the morning
thank you very much
item 11 housing provision Adventure
lands review Pages 62-71
um
[Music]
thank you uh I've got a number of slides
to run through uh I thought it'd be a
lot easier if we've got quite a few new
members who may not be up to speed to
some of the the work that was done
during the past Council to get to where
we are today uh which was brought the
report in my name and the leader's name
and it has been a team efforts of the
John and Adrian you know and make all
Umbra a little bit of support depend on
the questions and obviously strong and
having her put work into it as well
um so as we said the the reports and the
backgrounds on pages 60 to 64. they
really identifies a number of the steps
that the council has gone through uh
since this project was started
it really stands back to uh your last
strategic plan which was approved back
in October or the previous councils like
strategic plan I should say
um approved back in October 2020 when
councilors recognized uh that I was in
was an area of concern
um the price is increased in lack of
availability temporary accommodation Etc
would be the problem
um so what was decided was uh we'd run
some
workshops for for all councilors uh to
attend and that was supported by a
consultancy company called Arc who
facilitated those meetings with the kind
of wider housing expertise that the
council didn't have
um or in the uh transfer of our house
instruction years
so we took an options report uh to full
Council in November 21.
um where it comes to all counselors in
attendance unanimously agreed a number
of points to to review things around uh
liability Assessments in in the planning
process and the taking a review of the
council's owned land and buildings uh
and just draw them with an assessment to
the determine whether they had potential
to develop housing that's not to say we
were going to develop post you know them
and I'd come back to that shortly and
seek any funding opportunities to assist
with the delivery either through the the
lunch relief and the Brownfield sites or
through homes
that was then to be followed up with a
strategic session uh looking at some of
those results particularly from the the
assessment and start to deliver or
develop a delivery plan
to add a number of earlier workshops uh
looking at a range of sites in our
previous property
manager is responsible for bullying
together that's that initial uh troll of
the councils uh Associated list
um then with input from the property
Team Planning team and the rest of the
management team we've developed
12 sites that were initially presented
the ball Council back in July of 2022
uh and those sites included a an
external viability and cost Assessment
bill with the overarching principle that
they had potential for Housing
Development rather than they would be
developed for proposing
um so all we're following that then in
October of that year uh
11 of the 12 sites were approved to take
forward into more detailed uh business
pieces
outlining
further whether or not they'd have
potential for opposing an excellent
so during that period
um and what was going on
um we still had covid pandemic
restrictions particularly at the start
of that process
um we had a number of campaigns running
uh to stop the projects to the top uh
work on some other sites we'll take an
election period back in May this year
there's a significant upsturge in our
temporary accommodation the number of
people presenting for the council uh at
risk and actually in homelessness at the
top of that were escalated in
significantly
um towards 1.2 million uh in terms of
temporary accommodation
we had the the Russian invasion of
Ukraine so we had Refuge Refugee and
site and Asylum widen from the existing
Afghan schemes so there had to be an
element of some Focus uh shift we needed
to be dealing with uh what was not now
an immersion problem but uh a real live
situation
so during uh the period the beginning of
this calendar year and across the
election period uh which submitted uh
bids and applications for Brownfield
land release fund
um during last year we acquired study
house which I think which direction it's
just down down the road they're not far
away to convert into hostile
accommodation Hospital accommodation
being by far the more financial
financially viability use of buildings
um we received a grant and then uh just
a cure and deliver on site three modular
units at Southern house and they were
put in situ just before the end of this
calendar year
um discussions with the Departments
leveling up homes and Community homes
and communities uh negotiations
continued around the projects with
radish sleeper accommodation program
with residents part and in that scheme
well that changed uh dramatically During
the period with the president's point
out leaving the campus or to further
negotiate with in like a change to that
program and actually now almost secure
it we had the launch of two local
Authority housing and uh linked to
um the the refugee and the Asylum
dispersal particularly coming from
Afghan but whilst we've taken up uh the
first found
hlahf1 because of capacity and timing
issues we haven't been able to take up
uh the second scheme
so as I said we've
adopted our current Focus so it's been
tailored around co-designing solutions
to dealing with our temporary
accommodation demand and to manage and
accommodate and secure government
housing related funding allegations and
they have specific types of conditions
around the types of accommodation the
use of accommodation and the time frames
um to the types of accommodation
on the local Authority housing plan one
we have to provide a four bed uh
property for Afghan resettlement the use
of the the accommodation is for that in
the first instance but if there isn't a
call on that then the new image can be
used to manage our own internal temp
great accommodation
the time frames have been particularly
constraining so the hope is that we
we're aiming for a November 23 delivery
but we've been given an extension of
action updates of March 24th but that's
still quite a tight time frame
so we've been concentrating on land in
our ownership
mainly because of cost if we go to land
in our own on the ship it's easier to
control and deliver than trying to
acquire sites as many members will know
from some of the other projects we've
been trying to deliver and particularly
around delivery capacity and it also
then meets the objectives of the full
Council decision looking at our own land
holding specifically
on top of that then rather than
purchasing stock on the the open market
it does increase the stock of available
housing within the district
so you haven't got a 11 business cases
in front of you
um obviously it's been quite an effort
to get to where we are today and I'll
come back to the specifics of the
recommendation
um but what we've gone on to do is
categorize uh the Latin sites uh that
initially put forward the prime
rationalize them into a proper delivery
plan
so you'll see we've highlighted in the
green uh no sites which we would propose
deliver in in the first instance though
identified as being able to be progress
to balance in heaven quickly uh so
that's Pines Lane so the Bayview garages
just about the Pines Lane presence in
Langtry Packers Park gradually yeah it's
Lane Northern and Cleveland so all of
those are considered uh deliverable
within the shortest space of time so
that's what we target as page one
then we've got two sites highlighted in
Amber as Windmill Lane in Northern and
it will ever really Brown close in
Middleford so they considered uh with
potential but need more significant
design development and do diligence
before they could be progressed any
further so we identified those as uh our
phase two
then we've got a number of sites uh in
red
no sites unlikely to be developed or not
in the medium term so they are bone Hill
car park in northern part of South
Street car park in Warrington Clayton
Road and Springfield car park so they
are much more complicated to deliver for
a variety of reasons in their outlines
in in the report so the recommendation
for those red sites is to remove them
from the program
so what the proposals are is looking at
the two sources of external funding uh
that have been made available to us
through the rest of sleep accommodation
program and the local Authority housing
Planet one which is around 980
000 of our external Grant as I mentioned
earlier they're both time restricted uh
with an early dates for November 23 but
our head of legal and governance has
been liaison with the department and the
other view that that can be extended to
November to March 2024.
um as mentioned they both have Grant
conditions around they use so
specifically what they can be used on
both require much funding from the
Council of 1.3 million so it's 50
percent on the uh and much funding for
the uh Rush sleeper accommodation
program and 60 percent match funding for
the local Authority housing planning
program uh what we've been trying to
Target is identifying funding
um that doesn't need the council to
enter and increase its borrowing
information
and that teacher is identified on page
66 of your report uh so overall that
would provide an additional payment
units of accommodation and as mentioned
earlier if that is not needed for
housing
visited then it can be used for our own
temporary the foundation abuse
and so as I mentioned Julian just to
bring some of the new members of the
street so Charlie your house was
acquired during the last Council who
already cited three modular units
um at the flight and there's planning
already in place for further through
units and to redevelop the property and
the property is currently under
Redevelopment and refurbishment and
should be available for occupation uh
during the autumn
the Pines Lane sites we've identified
that there's a potential or positioning
six further modular units on that site
and as I said earlier we're seeking to
acquire a four bedroom property which is
required as part of the the grant
conditions but these these or this
option or range of options uh we see is
the best chance of delivering these
schemes within the time frames that are
stipulated and we also know from the
report is memory support for that
particular stage in Queensland
so there's eight uh recommendations in
the report
um so starting to press opposite the
public on the high sites highlighted in
green phase one
to continue to look at the Amber rated
sites at phase two one three completed
phase one not the progress with the
sites ranked and especially in red in
the report
approved submission of an application
for modular units on the Payne's Lane
site
approve the submission of a planning
application for site in the modular
units where any of the other sites in
the list green with the exception of
clean pivot which already has outline
planning permission and
supplementary Capital receipts have
already been
acted into
at her part and
the Western refuse side should I say
rather than meanwhile
um so then going on to provide six
temporary accommodation modular units by
match funding the half a million pounds
contribution to on uh the department
including an additional five percent
agency to take the cost up to just over
and then and the council's contribution
uh be independent from the reserves
identified in the report
um except the Grant from the local
Authority housing and with uh
supplementary match funding again with a
with a small contingency
um taking the cost to 1.26 million again
uh hadn't been identified from research
within reports and finally to add the
total of that to the the capital program
so 2.3 million uh for all those
and to acquire a four-bedroom property
purchase from Google uh local mortgage
okay happy to answer any questions if
there are any there Pastor Brunton
thank you chair uh well I'd like to move
the recommendations on page 68's name
um
and to say that uh really
the judicially have talked about the
workshop we had some time ago didn't we
when we looked at all these sites and
the workshop consisted of you know Ward
members who knew what it told me about
it and we
identified what were the goers and what
were the losers and unfortunately when
it went to full Council full camps were
decided and look at all and of course
didn't that throw a grenade in the works
ain't mine would kill him well I don't
know it's been a highlight time again
thank goodness and it stayed that way I
hope
but it brings us back to the other issue
about housing generally and and there's
been a lot of programs on Radio 4 how
many people listen to that but one of
the best was a Sunday afternoon to drive
me back my grand apparent duties now
yeah an obscured I don't have Australia
Sunday afternoon before there but never
mind but it was a really good debate
shared by Michelle as you've seen the uh
the presenter on BBC
and the general consensus was that our
planning is broken it's not a bit of
purpose it is not doing what it's
supposed to do and I'll welcome the
previous
um decision made by this Council then
we're going to do a competency uh new
review because hopefully we'll be ahead
of the game and actually putting in
stuff that works for our communities
we're not doing it these projects are
all very well but they're a drop in the
ocean they're not doing what we should
be really doing it in providing housing
for decent housing for people who are
already giving them sense for housing
there's going to need upgrading in less
than 10 years time because it's rubbish
in terms of its installation etc etc
for the environment so you know
we're not doing what we're supposed to
be doing but that does depend a bit on a
partnership between us and and central
government but we're on the ground here
we know what we need in our communities
we have a desire for affordable rental
accommodation it is unfortunate that the
next generation will never get one and
it will never get on the housing that is
going to be forever before they get here
in the meantime they'll be bringing up
their families in rented accommodation
so we should be providing that decent
rental accommodation he used to do it
decades ago
you know we did I was brought up on a
council say apartment well I have to say
initially
first 10 years of our life as a family
we lived in a hobble it was literally a
novel it was a high Cottage with no
amenities whatsoever I think some people
today would think well I'll take that
you know without a roof you'd leave but
we had a room that was about it so we do
need to tackle this problem and we need
to get this our our shortcomings really
up the line
we're on the ground we should be telling
the LGA the government this is what we
need in our communities help us provide
it because we got the will to do it we
just need the resources to follow it up
but this is a story it's not it is
thank you that's a question yes coach
let's ask a question um the four
bedroomed house there are officers
looking to buy a new one or are we going
to buy one that means work because that
will cost more
to develop it's looking for the right
property the the rights price
polish
yourself have our officers looked at any
properties yet which town are we talking
about because it was not in a village
Adrian yes if you would please
have looked at some properties in and
around the benefit area specifically to
meet the grant requirements that are
stimulated for a four bedroom property
and we've obviously been looking at the
property that is available on the market
without excessive work and that also has
reasonably environmental
standards and low running costs for the
end users
thank you
yes
um yeah just lumps the and top five
green sites together but you've been
used for more than reviews for Pines
Lane so I feel like we should have asked
the board then have used for all of the
sides are in the green so you haven't
had a broader vendors for the other
sites we haven't had that opportunity
but what would our views we haven't
developed a project for the other side
so we're going to clean board yet so
we're in that category as deliverable
but we'll have to prepare further
details and report back because we're
already identifying that weren't say
it's currently so we'd need to bring
another report back to it to Council on
the other SpongeBob once our project and
at that point uh what then the views
would be sold and included so the just
the client's name that will go forward
and the other four would have to come
back
um with the exception of three
importance because that's already uh
being identified
[Music]
1.1 million
casual look
yeah with regard to the four modular
pods that were already in the situation
at somebody house the baby
um not yet because they were uh on the
way on the building and they cited very
close to the building so it's not
obviously it wasn't uh Adrian probably
better on small it's not safe to be
doing the extent of work on site with
those modular units of those modular
units occupied at this time but they are
ready to be occupied
[Music]
foreign
or whatever and I haven't mentioned this
to other cancers before but um
accommodation on car Parks
um in Bristol they have these really
um nice units and there's one next to
George's Park in Bristol where they put
these modular
movies plus on stills
um in car parks where you don't lose all
the car parking
um and you have really nice
accommodation so they would have a car
park underneath that is also still an
outbreaking compartment it's just I'm
just mentioning that Vision said it
needs anything different idea I just
suggest that maybe if it was like that
it could be a little faster because I
don't know what they cost but obviously
you can stop
on if I know it was in there and get
them with a future
time ago or whatever
um
Smith
[Music]
thank you Joe I just like to express the
public side of religion on behalf of
great orange I think you want the
sleeping giant then and I think it was
interesting that somebody was talking
about angry days in the Civil War it
wasn't quite that bad but I'm just like
to say thank you and people can sleep
um
[Music]
thank you to the officers for all the
hard work they've done on this project
um and I want to just ask what the next
stage is as I think is it supposed to be
a strategic session for counselors and
when will that be
that's the next day
so the the next stage is assuming uh
what comes to the polluted night is
deliver this space one scheme then look
at the the other ski the other projects
in that green section that we will bring
in reports back to members to consider
those
we're not proposing having another
workshop at this stage you've got your
strategic planning workshop coming up in
two weeks time uh that's the opportunity
to re-emphasize uh what you may wish to
do around 1000 and assuming as I would
expect that to be still one of uh your
main themes
[Music]
this process is going to carry on but
I'm just trying to establish when will
be invited to consider the next process
when I mean what have you got a Target
date
was it supposed to be a housing crisis
emergency
[Music]
deliverability on how you've engaged
with the housing associations Etc at
what points to say at some point where
we'll be presented with all this and
make a decision on when will that be
again and we've got to bear in mind the
the level of capacity so all of this
work tends to be centered around the
small theater uh Adrian kind of leading
from the project side of things
um as well as uh doing a vast amount of
work on the clean Maritime and uh what
the waste and uh
um we've got to think about capacity as
well so we need to deliver these sites
then move on to the other doesn't mean
we won't be doing anything in the in the
background uh but if we don't get these
delivered within the time frame we'll
lose the funding
done
things
[Music]
and well because
you pay attention
not quite so much
foreign
[Music]
uh it's not part of that attendance
being allocated to this project this is
highlighted in the report where the
fundings coming from
um
a lot of the emphasis was on that we're
already going to be hitting definitely
hard and we needed to make adjustments
you've got quite a lot of money
available that didn't sound like
interest rate
um well in the in the report those
percentage Community Resources
identified there's an uh a significant
concern of additional granting from the
government uh during the latter part of
the Year planning income was up during
the latter part of the Year car parking
firm was up during the latter part of
the year
um and absolutely Newton obviously read
the report interest rates uh have gone
through the rule which greatly increased
the amount of income the council cash
that's also would be the case for
2023-24 particularly in terms of
interest rates have they continued to
increase uh so that's kind of generally
why we've got more money available and
clearly we couldn't foresee
um interest rates going from just above
naught percent to over foreign
I love the Target in perspective no I'd
actually like to ever recommend any time
um
that the council could answer a request
the landowners have come forward with
potential land for Community Land Trust
infection so I think we might have a
more suitable locations come forward
that way and I know councilor James the
leader is very passionate about
Community Land Trust so I'd like to add
that as a recommendation please
is that correct
um well it's able to make an amendment
uh the proposals being the
recommendations in the reports have been
uh proposed but not seconded as yet and
overcomes a couple of his proposing and
Amendment
foreign
[Music]
episode recommendation number is it
number nine it'll be number nine
um but the council that's how to request
the landowners come forward with
potential land or ENT land trusts to be
put into action
yeah that's it consideration for
consideration it is I think there might
be more suitable opinions
okay we'll get the vote on the on the
amendment but uh councilman Connor
Hawkins a member is
addendum or is is included under
it
I'm sorry
counselor bright
so approval
positions
or any other
anything any of the other side sorry
things I've authorized an a with the
exception of sequence which I'm at 100
in the mcspe definitely not available
so can you would if people on that plan
we approach already got outline planning
permission so that doesn't wouldn't need
any further money
I don't think that Steve would on the uh
um
any other sites are authorized in Penny
which is actually what's going to name
all these sites highlighted it's been
really really
importantly improve the recommendation
you found something for the planning
application for any of the green sites
yes
[Music]
by sites I think for us the page
allowing is needed to be getting
conditioners get payments in on those
sites is too strong and I think that
that recommendation should be altered to
say that we're okay with improvising
with Plains Lane which you have sought
War members for use for already but
we're not happy with you going ahead
with the other four green sides because
we haven't even asked Ward members as
far as I know they're here
[Music]
not specifically with a planning
application in mind
got a new Council since those
[Music]
as soon as possible and all the other
ones that are in the green box
as soon as a suitable plan
is put forward with a recommendation
council with board member of consent
it'll come back to this Council for
approval
okay so submitting a planning
application and still doesn't
necessarily mean you develop uh the
study itself
and as uh intervention uh or more
members had been sold and that was a
decision of a previous
um so I accept but that's still
accountable decision that's been made
um so as I said we bring a business case
back
um and I suspect that to be honest they
were probably running parallel anyway
it was once we develop
um proposal it's at some point probably
the due start and considering uh the
planning aspects and solidification
about our planning an application it
could ultimately you'd still want to
know if it's uh suitable and possible in
planning terms before we progress too
far
it's just that you said that uh
so what opinion
have been asked for but not for planning
that this is planning so what happened
to us opinion without saying it in
planning I think one member views would
sought in principle but when there is an
actual plan but forward or that is
proportionable forward to actually get
planning on it obviously World members
will be consulted again for their
remaining yeah
Mr Brightman
yeah uh yeah I would just rely
please
ignored some of those comments
[Music]
that this Council should be encouraging
landowners to consider providing land
for Community Land trusts I think if
it's part of this it complicates the
issue because of Community Land Trust
would actually invariably be involving
other styles of Finance private Finance
even this is specific to do with Council
finance and therefore I would I I
applaud the idea but I would have
thought it should be the subject of a
sec a specific Standalone uh notice
emotion or whatever rather than trying
to put it in here because
well that was my thoughts on it but it's
been proposed and it's been second and I
understand
you and I think what we need today
I sit on the whatever it is the second
hosting task force and there is a move
to bring in more Community Land across
and I think I agree with Cheryl we
should be doing well I've been doing it
for 20 years
um and I think we probably need a way of
bringing that forward specifically
rather than complicated him with what is
our policy
I'll withdraw that okay
as a matter of clarification
if executive on for anyone listening on
YouTube who lives in an iPhone area you
did mention the word hi good when you
talked about the paints and garages it
says in the report Highview and brackets
you know my understanding is those are
two totally separate areas in High View
I think it's understand
um
our project right it's kind of shape in
his head so is it a Bay View of Payne's
Lane
well the garage is that Pines Lane that
I was involved in the discussion um
originally the pine scene off of
wherever the state there is an early
large block of garages with two two rows
of garages quite a number of them those
are the ones that they were talking
about
foreign
[Music]
right
thank you Captain Morgan
so I believe in sport even before the
country
okay okay
[Music]
all in favor please show
food
again
anyone again understentions
[Music]
2294 and two extensions thank you
I was moving on the drive from 12 on the
on your agenda to answer questions
submitted on the procedure route A9 two
questions have been received three
questions three questions
uh on the first one is uh from the
country Lovato
especially that would you
you can ask your supplementary if you
wished it
um
but again
yeah
um
I just feel just in response to that
answer
um I just feel that our councilor plans
aren't designed or designated board
like never imagined with my mother but
they were supposedly
[Music]
that's true
situations arrive arise or even
detrimentally affecting the very popular
Apple door Book Festival which brings in
a huge influx of people into the area in
Europe
um it's recently being brought to my
attention that as a result of
prologistic council handing over control
of Applebee to Jasmine fancy of that so
much the use of the key for events
associated with respectable in
particular the through the family fun
day
um
not make a mistake sorry you're not
meant to make a statement okay
um so
it's happening to Ecuador there's a
suggestion because I thought he is now
designated as a highway the suggestion
is that we use the car part of the free
Family Fun Day which again I bring this
same problem of the cost of car parking
fees you know go to the local Traders
are giving their time and their money to
make this free day possible for it and
again these charitable events are
getting hammered by
the unexpected costs of the car park
fees and I would argue that you make
plenty of money from car parking because
these events pull in people who live in
German Center is being done and I think
it's an unnecessary thing to charge
charitons for the car parking in them
okay
thank you all right
yeah so the next question is from uh
Council Thomas
um
you actually understood my question it
was the point I was making was not to do
with the process it was to do the
communication with counselors and the
public
the answer refers to what the council
Palms do but I don't think it really
relates to my question about whether the
council should be better with actually
communicating the situation with members
and the public so we can explain why the
council can't do certain things and why
it can be and you think maybe you should
prove communication of the counselors
when situations like the Victoria Park
on Iran is I think that's a good point
that I wouldn't probably support that
yeah
first part first paragraph refers to uh
to review a BB provision on my own
hospital that will come to the climate
working group before it comes through
CNR whatsoever
used to me that much and the other one
um starting upon it's been to discuss
with current leading providers about
reliability of even points in our car
parts
um well it would be nice to know where
those discussions got to because I think
the labrador charging Point's been out
of action about two years when I was
standing so apparently just asked you
know well within these discussion is
this you know it's not encouraging
people to buy electric vehicles and it's
not helping our thoughts upon you know
we've got these unreliable charging
thank you
yeah thank you so so yes of course with
the agreement that the care of the
climate change working group we can
bring a report back there in due course
um I think it would be unfair of me to
start talking about the exact
performance of this could have done of
this Statistics in front of me but my
discussions with uh Steve in the parking
team thing that we've got problems with
the charging units have been
intermittent they haven't actually been
out of uh use all the time they're in
and out abuse although the app does say
that they're often out of use that is
unacceptable we have been discussing
that with the with the uh the company
that that leased the space and provide
the units for us and I think that will
all be wrapped up in the report that
comes back that you'll see in due voice
foreign
because things were being
um they were on a national
um database people were coming and
expecting people to charge so
um the application is not just an
intermittent writing
thank you
item 13 petitions we've got three
petitions have been received and
achieved executable land trainers
thanks Jay just got a couple of slides
this time
um so I guess your members maybe
wondering why there's three petitions to
this kid
um all in relation to South Street Car
hard don't be there to come to operates
uh petitions team uh so a pack of
petitions were handed in as is required
uh the team then uh review and look
through what's being submitted uh
clearly there's no signing Edition need
to be from within the District of orange
um so when the petitions submitted were
looked at
um you'll see there's two
um with several differences the first
one
ended with already run to it or are
imminent and for whatever reason
unbeknown to us
um the second position petition went on
and changed the word imminent imminently
and started suggesting or making
suggestions that were supposed to be the
car part was uh or is a premium site
which is really quite different from the
original petition
um so when the team looked through that
so there was
1741 signatures for petition 1 1 376
petition on petition signatures on
petition 2 and 43 on petition 3 and
petition three and simply said Dave is
not doing far hard obviously there's a
significant number
um particularly from the the online
version that were rejected I think there
are signatures from Mexico South Africa
and a range of places which clearly were
unable to accept
um the petition scheme within the
Constitution
um allows potential
um for them to be or petitioned to be
Amalgamated
um but these two the two main petitions
submitted uh do offer quite a different
view of the sacraments talking about
searching car park being a premium signs
so therefore those who sign in the first
position we couldn't say uh accurately
that they would sign the second one
um so ultimately we couldn't add them
together so taken separately if they
don't go over the specials
um in addition to the reopening sentence
of the petitions talking about
um planning Pros planning proposals and
clearly there's no planning proposals
being submitted at this stage
um as it refers to why the proposals and
no proposals in place to this the page
the petition the petition uh be an
entrepreneur and clearly the item 11 on
tonight's agenda recommendation which
was approved to not progressively
assigned anywhere and chair so in that
instance we'd just simply write back to
the petition organization
thank you
a lot of ways of resulted
on the same petition everyone was
signing it deciding for the same reason
the same what the way you just put it
everyone knows it was the same
efficiency
from having housing on it and that's
quite clear I'm pretty sure that
everyone understands that
yeah I think it needs to be pointed out
that you know just to shrunk of this
decision so easily you know you have
forgotten that you had actually offended
everyone in Torrington because you
deliberately tried to sabotage an attack
over what you've done
yes
all right
okay
is uh item 14 we have three Notions
notices emotion it got made welcome
cancer well one from Massachusetts
[Music]
thank you chair I will be brief
I think we should call ourselves
tarrington District Council though
uh situation is such that I've made a
request for microphones and I think our
leader made a wonderful case for me
tonight and he said I'll stand up and go
to a microphone so I could be heard and
normally Kevin sits over there it's the
first time I've heard you for 40 years
ago
two points uh we brief International
about saving a lot of time sometimes I
can't hear what's set on that side of
the room because we have a bit of a
barrier here between the rooms okay and
the same boats is and goes back and
forth and it's very difficult
I'm also on Palms committee it's
interesting on pounds committee when I
when I got a sad life because I do dance
committee no I don't even go back and
look at it a second time to see what I'm
accused of saying which is quite
interesting I'm always amazed how good
the recordings are at pounds committee
uh Kirsten Newton says an awful lot of
policy but he's been there every time
representative winkley I think for the
last three months so you've done a great
job you want to hear it then I come to
Capstone and it's very difficult
some time to hear what members say and
I've had it said to me our members on
the same parity as officers because
officers have microphones to speak into
where members voices aren't put forward
and I'm really Keen that we have
microphones that record what members
have to say because members views are
vitally important particularly new
counselors as well for the direction of
this Council so our elected proposition
for
um our officer Tom vanstone to work on
something that puts a better microphone
system in so that we can be hired at
Capstone on YouTube in the same way we
can at the the tow ball and that is what
I'm asking you to vote on tonight I call
for a second there be quick about it and
we'll move on to the next proposal
maybe it was just first
I don't know second cancer Pennington
being at the far end I accept I was
about the most difficult position
but I would also ask everyone
to remember who you're talking to
many of you have the habit of directing
your conversation directly at the person
at the microphone
the rest of the room is not listening to
you
[Music]
thank you
Mr Greg Anthony
said some people do speak louder than
others and it's important that everyone
does get hurt and everyone is able to
hear what everyone else is
good yeah
okay
he's very sorry that you can't hear me
over there I really I do apologize for
that but
probably easily so let's get back to the
channel this this place is rubbish you
get members of the public sat over there
who can't hear what people over here are
saying for example and we can't see them
and who they are the town hall has got
much better Acoustics down there and
repentance just said it but the planets
we wouldn't need to follow with a
microphones it's much better down there
and
um my wife just pointed out eyesight you
can't see some of the stuff that's on on
the screens here because it's so far
away
that is where the public goes and that's
what they recognize Tori's main the
baking chamber is what on Earth are we
doing stick it over here up here because
of Kobe and that's all that's good well
that hasn't gone but it's diminished so
we could go back to the town hall I hate
it up here okay thank you okay but it's
been proposed and seconded
that
we investigate a better microphone
system for use by members quite how
that's going to be a cheap I have no
idea
well maybe you're wondering why whatever
but anyway big proposal again
[Music]
um
to investigating that right
yes
we have sentient
40.2 against the forums
all right come on today
next there was a motion which was
for myself and involves a normal light
I'm not going to go into a lot of debate
on this I'm not going to any debate on
it what I am going to suggest is that we
refer to the climate and working group
for them to consider this on the Growers
that I would I would ask them to to take
into consideration uh areas like
Victoria Park
um some of our more important Town
Center brass verges roundabouts Etc and
also our cemeteries I've had lots and
lots of complaints from residents about
the uh the state of particularly higher
cemetery and I think that's very
disrespectful when people go to them
football cemetery and the grass is too
big tall it just looked at once again
orange doesn't care
[Music]
since the 1970s we're one of the worst
in Europe a while ago councilman bushby
is suggesting that seemingly that we
raise the grass to near the Earth and
not have any long grass areas most
councils are now leaving areas of normal
grass in the public spaces recognizing
that it's highly important for wildlife
we have an obligation as a council under
a legislation to promote biodiversity we
have to declare the climate of urgency
um we have subscribed to the next for
your plans with the buyers spam and we
have our department environment by
diversity plan so I am alarmed by his
suggestion about surveys that would
welcome you talking about houses at
climate group I should tell everybody
that survivability plan is being
prepared by the Estates Department which
is drawing up plans for areas where we
could leave areas longer
um I appreciate that there is a public
concern over perceptions of titanicity
as you received from other authorities
in Southern Country they set off long
areas of grass with known areas of
lodging areas and and this makes it more
acceptable how bad is being drawn up at
the working group and we look forward to
those end of it to what probably CNR
thank you thank you thank you for that
great summary
um
we don't need any more debate on this I
mean equality
how briefly can you please remember
thank you well I was really relieved to
Steve all
wild flowers and the Elephant a range of
grasses being streamed so heaven knows
more by the Town Council Workman and
Little America because we do need our
lay bars to be streamed by their crew
cars but really the boots on the other
foot isn't it
um you've got it all wrong it's the
state of the town that is awful it's the
streets there what's public space as
well and they're in a dire staying with
the buildings are in a dire State that's
what we need to look at not a totally
home though walking after the rain says
not the small areas that have glass and
wild flowers I haven't heard anybody
complain about that but I have heard
them complain about the awful state of
the streets the litter in the from the
Sea Gold attacking the plastic bag we
only get done once the once upon a time
that's the real issue of public spaces
in our towns particularly beautiful but
also tourism because I've seen it there
that's what people really care about and
what they're really concerned about not
beautiful wild flowers and they lovely
different range of grasses that
occasionally pop themselves up in our
public spaces thank you thank you
Christie has an invitation yes on the
Town Council
um I put a motion to them to set up a
tidy Town room
it's going to be a joint one with
torrage uh I invite you to join
councilor Brendan brightness
has been proposed and has been secondary
curvature fans to agree this motion to
go to the climate looking good to
consider
not cut in various areas
again
abstentions
it's really
um
show again that all those in support of
the milkshake
motion is to send it to the point
climate working group for their
considerations
against
other sanctions
did you have your hand up at some point
sorry 14-4 or against
it
no that doesn't work
um
please show clearly put your hand on it
foreign
against
yes
as
um well I can withdraw that because it
works that I I was asking are mental
solution I've been largely candidate
buyer officer like Amendment thank you
I think one of those are a constitution
that you have to have a second
it doesn't really matter
yeah
[Music]
thank you
yeah
I did I didn't need to have a second
I'll do that connection
so the meeting ends up one minute pass
on and thank you very much
foreign